-In the span of
just a few hours,
President Trump caved
on the signature promise
of his campaign
and one of his closest advisers
was indicted in
the Russia investigation.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's not often
that a single event
sums up an entire presidency,
but on Friday,
we got one
that came pretty close.
Remember, Trump brags that he
only hires the best people,
calls the Russia investigation
a hoax,
calls CNN fake news,
and his government shutdown
left FBI agents without pay.
So it was especially ironic
when one of Trump's
closest associates was arrested
by unpaid FBI agents working
for the special counsel
in the Russia investigation,
and the whole thing
was caught on tape by CNN.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The only way --
The only way that could have
been more humiliating for Trump
is if Robert Mueller celebrated
by eating a Happy Meal
at McDonald's, on a date
with Stormy Daniels.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And you know, when Trump first
heard about the arrest,
he was furious to find out
that the FBI
hadn't also been shut down.
[ As Trump ] What?
I thought there were no laws
during the shutdown, like
in that movie "The Purge."
[ Laughter ]
When do I get my purge?
[ Normal voice ] When, in fact,
the FBI was affected
by the shutdown.
But that didn't stop them
from making the arrest.
-These FBI agents making
this arrest of Roger Stone
in Fort Lauderdale this morning,
like every other FBI agent,
they're not being paid
right now.
800,000 federal workers begin
missing their second paycheck
this week.
-Wow.
Imagine being such an ass[Bleep]
that FBI agents
will come into work
and arrest you for free.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"If you think I'm coming in --
Oh, Roger Stone?
Yeah, on my way.
[ Laughter ]
Somehow, the day managed to get
even more humiliating for Trump,
because just a few hours later,
Trump was forced to cave
on the signature promise
of his campaign
and reopen the government
without money
for his border wall.
After 35 days of subjecting
millions of people
to needless suffering and pain,
Trump gave up.
And he did it
in true Trump fashion
by rambling aimlessly
about walls.
-Walls work. They do work.
No matter where you go,
they work.
We have barriers at the border
where natural structures
are as good
as anything that we can build.
They're already there.
They've been there
for millions of years.
[ Laughter ]
Last year alone,
ICE officers removed
10,000 known or "suspested"
gang members,
like MS-13 and
members as bad as them.
Horrible people.
Tough, mean, sadistic.
Think of that.
we apprehended 60,000 people.
That's like a stadium
full of people.
A big stadium.
-Man, even right after suffering
a humiliating defeat,
he still talks like the guy
in front of me in line
at the pharmacy.
"Wow, a whole stadium, huh?
Cool.
Hey, um, they're calling you.
They have your pills."
[ Laughter ]
And because
the speech made no sense,
Trump later had to follow up
on Twitter
and insist that
even though he caved
without getting
anything he wanted,
he had actually won.
-The president wrote, "I wish
people would read or listen
to my words on the border wall.
This was
in no way a concession."
-Yeah, we did listen.
You said "suspested."
[ Laughter and applause ]
We were listening.
Also, if you have to tell people
it wasn't a concession,
then it was
definitely a concession,
like that time Custer wrote home
from Little Bighorn,
"This was in no way
my last stand."
[ Laughter ]
Trump caved after 35 days,
got nothing.
You got to give credit
to the air traffic controllers,
flight attendants,
TSA screeners,
and custom agents who showed
the power of labor solidarity.
And you got to give credit
to House Speaker Nancy Pelosi,
who held out long enough
and kept her caucus together.
Meanwhile, Republicans spent the
last few days of the shutdown
at each other's throat.
-Frustration is growing among
Republicans on Capitol Hill,
and we quote,
"Republican Senators clashed
with one another and confronted
Vice President Pence
inside a private luncheon
on Thursday
as anger hit a boiling point
over the longest government
shutdown in history."
'This is your fault,'
Senator Ron Johnson told
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
at one point,
according to two Republicans
who attended the lunch
and witnessed the exchange.
'Are you suggesting
I'm enjoying this?'
McConnell snapped back."
-First of all, Mitch McConnell
doesn't enjoy anything.
[ Laughter ]
I think, at the very most,
he has a rudimentary
nervous system
that allows him
to respond to light and heat.
[ Laughter ]
Enjoyment is beyond him.
Here he is in a bouncy house.
[ Laughter ]
Here's Mitch McConnell
doing a cannonball.
[ Laughter ]
Second, it's all of your fault.
You could have ended
the shutdown at any time,
but you subjected millions of
people to needless misery
for a President who lied
and a wall that won't work.
In other words, you're all...
-Horrible people.
-So the shutdown gave us
more evidence
that Trump is not the master
deal-maker he claimed to be.
And the indictment of Stone,
who has been one of
his closest associates,
gave us more evidence
that he does not, in fact,
hire the best people.
Now, if you're not familiar
with Roger Stone,
he's the third one.
[ Laughter ]
He's also a longtime
political dirty trickster,
known for his shady tactics
and his bizarre outfits.
This is his actual outfit
from the inauguration,
and by far the best thing
about his arrest is
we can make fun of
this picture again.
I mean, look at that.
Did Quentin Tarantino
remake "Lincoln"?
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know "Downton Abbey"
had a pimp.
[ Laughter ]
If he weren't
a political consultant,
he'd be the world's oldest
chimney sweep.
He looks like he got kicked out
of the Magic Castle for vaping.
[ Laughter ]
Mueller arrested him
on seven counts of perjury
and five counts
of looking like
Teddy Roosevelt's deadbeat dad.
By the way, that isn't even the
only insane outfit he's worn.
Look at all these.
These look like headshots
from the poster of
a one-man show
called, "My Mother is Italian,
My Father is Jewish,
and I'm in Jail."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Stone got his start in politics
working for both Richard Nixon's
presidential campaigns,
and he loves Nixon so much,
he famously has Nixon's face
tattooed on his back.
Although it's equally possible
that the tattoo
just burned itself into his skin
while he was sleeping.
"You have the mark!"
And after Stone left
the courthouse on Friday,
he celebrated his political hero
by doing the Nixon victory pose
for the cameras.
Now, you might be thinking
to yourself,
"Didn't Nixon resign
in disgrace?
Maybe that's not the best pose
to show you're innocent."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But Stone doesn't remember that,
because he spent most
of the '70s
traveling the world
in a glass elevator
he stole from Willy Wonka.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And if I were Stone,
I'd be afraid of the parallels,
because Nixon's presidency
ended, in part, over charges
that he obstructed justice,
and the indictment
against Stone alleges
that he was very intent
on interfering
in Mueller's investigation.
For example,
Stone sent an e-mail
to a guy named Randy Credico,
a radio host
who allegedly acted
as an intermediary
with WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange.
And in that e-mail, Stone
tried to get Credico to lie
by citing a character
from "The Godfather"
as an example to follow.
-The special counsel
also indicted Stone
for witness tampering.
This for allegedly attempting to
sway radio host Randy Credico,
allegedly a go-between
with Assange,
before Credico testified
to Congress.
The indictment alleges
that Stone said Credico
"should do a Frank Pentangeli,"
referring to a character
in "The Godfather: Part II"
who lied to Congress.
-That's right.
Stone literally told the witness
to do a Frank Pentangeli,
a character in "The Godfather"
who lies to Congress.
This guy was basically begging
to be arrested.
I mean, he imitates
Richard Nixon,
he quotes from "The Godfather,"
and he dresses likes
Hannibal Lecter.
[ Laughter ]
But Stone's e-mail to Credico
got weirder.
Stone allegedly
threatened Credico
in an attempt to keep him quiet
during the investigation.
And at one point,
according to the indictment,
Stone even suggested he would
steal Credico's therapy dog.
According to an e-mail
included in the indictment,
Stone also said he would
"take that dog away from you."
Man, it really doesn't
help your case
when you make the same threats
as the Wicked Witch of the West.
[ Laughter ]
He actually threatened
to steal the guy's dog.
How much more of a villain
can you be?
"I'll steal that dog of yours,
and then it's off to Monte Carlo
in my autogyro!"
[ Laughter ]
That's it.
That was the last one
about his outfit.
Yet even after threatening
another guy's dog,
Stone had the audacity
to complain
about the FBI's treatment of him
in a courthouse press conference
on Friday.
-This morning,
at the crack of dawn,
29 FBI agents arrived
at my home,
with 17 vehicles
with their lights flashing,
when they could simply have
contacted my attorneys.
And I would have been
more than willing
to surrender voluntarily.
They terrorized my wife,
my dogs.
-Oh, now
you're worried about dogs?
[ Laughter ]
Well, I hate to break it to you,
buddy,
but when they heard you
threaten one of them,
they flipped on you.
[ Laughter ]
It's clear.
[ Applause ]
[ Barking ]
[ Laughter ]
It's clear what's going on here.
Stone is obviously angling
for a pardon from Trump,
who has shown a willingness
to praise witnesses
who refuse to cooperate
and attack those who do.
And to get that pardon,
Stone has been going on TV,
complaining about the FBI
and the media
to win Trump's favor,
like in this interview
he did on "Fox News Friday."
-It's disconcerting that CNN was
aware that I would be arrested
before my lawyers were informed.
That's disturbing.
If it was a dangerous situation
which would merit
the SWAT team,
well, then CNN's cameraman
would be in danger.
I'm not a flight risk.
In fact, I think my passport
has expired or
it will expire in a few days.
-That's silly.
You don't need a passport
to travel via magic umbrella.
[ Laughter ]
I lied. That was the last one.
One after another, the
President's closest associates
are being indicted
or going to jail.
Trump says he only
hires the best,
but Stone's indictment
is more proof
that Trump surrounds
himself with...
-Horrible people.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]